la pregunta es esta la economía china
acerca de experimentar una enorme crisis
económica y financiera puede conocido
como modelo chino llegar a colapsar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas en 2020 el
gobierno chino se las prometía muy
felices el país había hecho frente a la
guerra comercial desatada por donald
trump y fue uno de los primeros países
en contener la pandemia del sars
coronavirus 2 incluso a pesar de ser el
origen de la propia pandemia la economía
china tuvo uno de los mejores desempeños
del mundo sin embargo desde entonces las
cosas han cambiado casi por completo
fijaos 7 de julio de 2022 el crecimiento
de china se ralentiza bruscamente
poniendo fuera de alcance el objetivo
del pib durante el segundo trimestre del
2022 la economía china apenas creció un
0,4 por ciento respecto al mismo
trimestre del año anterior fue salvando
el coronavirus el peor dato de los
últimos 30 años y pone contra las
cuerdas el objetivo del 5,5 por ciento
de crecimiento que el gobierno de xi
jinping se había marcado para todo el
año
[Música]
y es que olvida todo lo que recordáis
sobre los éxitos de chinas porque ahora
el escenario es completamente distinto
desde la segunda mitad del 2021 ha sido
formando en el gigante asiático una
especie de torbellino económico el
desempleo juvenil está a punto de
superar la cifra del 20 por ciento la
actividad comercial se ha frenado hasta
el punto de que en términos reales las
ventas minoristas están en negativo los
precios de las viviendas llevan cayendo
desde el verano del 2021 y para colmo
tal e como podéis ver en pantalla la
fuga de capitales del país se ha
disparado comiéndose con ello gran parte
del enorme superávit comercial que sigue
teniendo china china está en problemas
lejos de los titulares de taiwán las
salidas de capital son ahora tan grandes
como cuando el susto de la devaluación
del renminbi de
2015-2016 esto se debe a la fortaleza
del dólar ya que los inversores
extranjeros vieron a china bajo una
nueva perspectiva tras la invasión rusa
de ucrania robyn brooks economista jefe
del instituto de finanzas
internacionales incluso el crecimiento
de la casa de una de las joyas de la
corona' de la economía china se ha
volatilizado fijaos
de hecho gigante es como alibaba ha
tensado diddy entre otros muchos están
llevando a cabo un enorme cantidad de
despidos en parte por el mal momento
económico y en parte porque la presión
ejercida por pekín sobre estas empresas
ha dañado su rentabilidad las grandes
empresas tecnológicas de china están
despidiendo a miles de trabajadores el
caso es que este panorama ha obligado al
gobierno a pedirle a las grandes
empresas públicas y al propio aparato
del estado que contraten a más jóvenes
para que las cosas no se escapen de
control pero claro eso no parece sino
pan para hoy y hambre para mañana quizás
la única buena noticia que ha tenido la
economía china durante el primer
semestre del 2022 fue que a pesar de
todo la inversión extranjera directa se
incrementó con fuerza pero como veis son
muchos más los datos negativos que los
positivos así que la pregunta es hasta
dónde llegan los problemas de la
economía china porque las cosas parecen
de repente tan preocupantes que tan
cerca está china vivir un posible
colapso económico y quizás la pregunta
más importante de todas que piensa hacer
si jinping para evitar que china sufra
su primera gran crisis en más de 50 años
pues atentos
[Música]
hasta donde llegan los problemas
a contracorriente con el resto del mundo
a mediados de agosto del 2022 y el banco
popular de china decidió reducir los
tipos de interés 15 de agosto del 2022
china da la sorpresa con una bajada de
tipos mientras los datos muestran una
desaceleración alarmante y no sólo eso
sino que al mismo tiempo el gobierno
anunció también un incremento del gasto
público hubo momentos en los tipos y más
gasto público esto quiere decir que el
gobierno chino se comporta como si el
país estuviera ya en crisis incluso en
recesión que por otra parte es lo que
también nos dicen los datos que vamos
conociendo y es que a ver saber
exactamente lo que ocurre en china pues
no resulta nada fácil no hablamos
precisamente del país más transparente
del mundo sin embargo la situación
parece incluso peor que lo que refleja
el crecimiento del pib estimado por el
gobierno pero claro e insisto hablamos
de china un país que oficialmente no ha
experimentado un crecimiento negativo y
tras la masacre de tiananmen y durante
la crisis financiera el 97 ni tampoco en
la del 2007 así que el hecho de que
china haya publicado prácticamente su
peor dato de los últimos 30 años ya nos
dice mucho de cómo están las cosas no
precisamente bien pero ahora bien
realmente hasta dónde llegan los
problemas de china cuáles son los
mayores agujeros que por hoy tienen el
gigante asiático pues bien presta mucha
atención porque estos son los cuatro
grandes problemas que hoy por hoy
complican el futuro económico de este
país y la posible respuesta del gobierno
para intentar revertir los malos datos
que hemos visto
el primero de ellos tiene mucho que ver
con el propio funcionamiento básico de
la economía china y es que veréis
mientras que en la mayor parte del mundo
el pib es una medida de lo que se ha
producido en un país durante un periodo
de tiempo en el caso de china la cosa es
algo distinta si el pib mide exactamente
lo mismo pero la diferencia está en que
es un indicador determinado
políticamente con antelación es decir el
gobierno fija un objetivo de crecimiento
y luego impulsar a todos los actores
públicos y privados e intentar
alcanzarlo es el efecto directo de la
planificación
y os preguntaréis dónde está el problema
pues básicamente en que cuando los
funcionarios creen que no se va a
alcanzar ese crecimiento ponen sobre la
mesa todo tipo de tretas y de medidas
para intentar conseguirlo
por ejemplo se lanzan como locos a
construir infraestructuras y todo tipo
de proyectos hacen que las empresas
públicas se pongan a contratar como si
no hubiera mañana y también por supuesto
expanden sin frenos el crédito por
ejemplo para que las familias pues
compren más y más viviendas y esto
impulsa el crecimiento todo con tal de
alcanzar el objetivo para colmo la
inmensa mayor parte del sector bancario
en china es público es decir trabaja
para cumplir los propios objetivos del
gobierno y se hace falta más crecimiento
pues se ponen como locos a conceder
nuevos créditos incluso aunque se lo
tienen a personas o empresas con dudosa
capacidad de pago no importan tienen que
cumplir sí o sí con los objetivos de
concesión de créditos que ha marcado el
estado para que estos objetivos a su vez
ayuden a lograr los objetivos de
crecimiento y veis dónde está el
problema
[Música]
en cualquier caso durante años esto no
fue estrictamente un inconveniente
porque china estaba básicamente intra
invertida tenía pocas infraestructuras
pocas empresas y pocas viviendas así que
todo lo que se hacía era tremendamente
productivo sin embargo desde hace unos
10 ó 15 años la situación ha cambiado
por completo sin haber construido tanto
que por ejemplo las nuevas
infraestructuras o la ampliación de
capacidad de las empresas públicas pues
ya no son rentables es decir no generan
retornos suficientes como para compensar
toda la inversión realizada el resultado
un enorme espiral de deuda fijaos amigos
amigas la deuda en china ha crecido
tanto que tan sólo entre los años 2007 y
2017 se multiplicó por 4 luego que
supone un incremento mayor que el de
cualquier otro país del mundo de hecho
en términos de pib los chinos tienen hoy
más deuda circulando que los propios
eeuu y sabéis que esto nos lleva
directamente al segundo problema
mientras la deuda ha crecido mucho la
productividad que al fin y al cabo es lo
que determina en gran medida la
capacidad de pagar esas deudas se ha
desplomado y esto hace que china tenga
que invertir muchos muchísimos recursos
para mantener el crecimiento inversión
que se financia con deuda y que sin
embargo genera pocos beneficios y
queridos amigos amigas aquí os hago una
pregunta qué ocurre cuando tu deuda se
dispara tu capacidad de pago se reduce y
encima tu economía entra en crisis y si
pierdes ingresos pues que tienes un
problema y sobre todo tus bancos tienen
un problema porque pues porque puede que
muchos de sus créditos entren en mora es
decir que los deudores no puedan
devolverlos y justo este es el tercer
gran riesgo que se enfrenta a la
economía china la posibilidad de sufrir
una enorme crisis financiera ahora bien
sobre esta cuestión en concreto os
hablará muy pronto y con todo lujo de
detalles en si lo hubiera sabido el
canal de información financiera de
mutuactivos con el que participamos si
aún no lo conocéis os dejo por aquí
abajo el link para que le echéis un
vistazo y si os gusta o suscribiros por
ejemplo así podréis saber exactamente
hasta qué punto china puede estar cerca
de sufrir una enorme crisis financiera y
bancaria pero bien luego junto a estos
tres grandes problemas se suma un cuarto
muy relacionado con ellos y con todo lo
que os hemos contado la implosión el
reventón del mercado inmóvil
ah
el sector inmobiliario chino es
gigantesco para que os hagáis una idea
tan solo en 2021 se vendieron en china
2,4 millones de dólares millones
hispanos de viviendas directa e
indirectamente este sector supone casi
el 30 por ciento de toda la economía
china así que poca broma hablamos de uno
de los principales motores económicos
del gigante asiático pues bien desde el
verano del 2021 las cosas en este sector
van de mal en peor y tanto la inversión
como la venta de viviendas como los
precios se están desplomando
15 de agosto del 2022 bomba de relojería
la crisis inmobiliaria en china se
agrava al caer los precios de la
vivienda por undécimo mes consecutivo y
eso no es todo capital economics una
consultora con sede en londres apunta
que a finales del 2021 en china había
aproximadamente 30 millones de
propiedades no vendidas y cerca de 100
millones más que estarían vendidas pero
no ocupadas
[Música]
y evidentemente suponiendo una parte tan
grande de la economía china el reventón
del sector inmobiliario es algo que
potencialmente puede ser muy pero que
muy serio para el conjunto de la
economía nacional el desplome de esta
industria podría provocar por ejemplo
cientos de miles millones de
desempleados el colapso de muchas
promotoras muchos más problemas para los
bancos y un empobrecimiento general de
los chinos por la pérdida de valor de
sus propiedades pensaban que las casas
pues forman la mayor parte del
patrimonio de las familias de este país
y si su precio que hay estas familias
con hipotecas enormes a sus espaldas se
volverán de repente mucho más pobres la
situación amigos es tan delicada que
vídeos como este se han hecho virales en
las redes chinas fijaos
como
colinas
[Música]
yo sí
por supuesto no parece que haya margen
para que eso pueda ocurrir y ni siquiera
aparece algo aconsejable fijaos
pero seguimos el quinto problema que
tiene tiene por delante tiene mucho que
ver con la guerra de ucrania
[Música]
la guerra comercial iniciada por donald
trump y la creciente beligerancia de
pekín dio la señal de alarma para muchas
empresas ahora la invasión rusa de
ucrania junto a la política kobe y cero
del gobierno chino han vuelto a poner
sobre la mesa el riesgo geopolítico y la
importancia de asegurar las cadenas de
suministro esto puede hacer que durante
los próximos años muchas multinacionales
trasladen parte de sus operaciones al
menos concentren sus nuevas inversiones
fuera de china esto es algo que todavía
no ha ocurrido pero si se sabe que las
empresas están preocupadas así que si
finalmente se frena la inversión de las
empresas extranjeras en el país esto
podría suponer un duro golpe para el
crecimiento económico de china es decir
podría dificultar seriamente la
recuperación y para colmo en un plazo
inmediato la crisis energética
internacional podría terminar causando
una caída en las exportaciones chinas
que agraven aún más los problemas
económicos que ya tiene este gigante
[Música]
y luego por último aunque no sea algo
que vaya a tener consecuencias en un
futuro mediato a medio y largo plazo sí
que tenemos que tener en cuenta la
cuestión demográfica
[Música]
si no está envejeciendo a toda velocidad
de hecho es muy probable que la
población en edad de trabajar ya se esté
reduciendo qué es exactamente lo que
también ocurrirá con la población del
país durante los próximos años en esta
línea en 2021 en las tasas de natalidad
chinas cayeron a un mínimo histórico y
evidentemente una población más pequeña
y más envejecida pues se traducirá en
más gasto público o menos dinamismo
económico y una deuda per cápita más
alta pues bien el caso es que estos
cinco grandes riesgos o seis incluimos
el declive demográfico pueden suponer un
frenazo un serio viento de cara para el
vuelo económico de china si no se
gestionan adecuadamente estos problemas
pueden incluso terminar provocando una
enorme crisis económica y financiera en
el gigante asiático así que la pregunta
es correr llamado modelo chino el riesgo
de colapsar qué demonios piensa hacer el
gobierno de sikkim pin para revertir
esta situación pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
el gran fracaso de xi jinping
ya sé lo que muchos estaréis pensando a
ver enrique todos los países
experimentan en algún que otro momento
alguna crisis económica monetaria o
financiera desde eeuu hasta la unión
europea pasando por japón o corea del
sur es mi hablemos ya de américa latina'
entonces no es algo exagerado hablar del
posible colapso del modelo chino porque
unos cuantos datos económicos no marchen
bien pues sí y al mismo tiempo no
[Música]
desde hace décadas el modelo chino ha
consistido en garantizar una rápida
mejora en los niveles de vida a cambio
de que los chinos no cuestionarán el
gobierno y el poder del partido
comunista digamos que ha sido algo así
como una especie de acuerdo tácito no
escrito que ha legitimado a los
gobiernos chinos y fue así durante los
mandatos de de esa opinión zemin y hu
jintao para conseguirlo la apertura y la
integración de china en la economía
mundial fue algo imprescindible os
acordáis de esa época cuando los
mandatarios chinos aparecían en las
televisiones de los hogares
estadounidenses recitando a lincoln y
deseando la amistad entre los pueblos
for school and the seven years the world
golf a 2 por posiciones continentales
con shift inglés break entendí que sweet
proposition that o make it right in
people sin embargo las cosas han
cambiado y bayas han cambiado y aún
siguen cambiando con xi jinping desde
que el actual vídeo se hiciera con el
timón en el 2012 el gobierno empezó a
intervenir más en la economía el
crecimiento se ha desacelerado y además
para intentar tener tasas de crecimiento
más altas la deuda de las empresas de
las familias y del sector público se ha
multiplicado
de esta forma los datos han ido poco a
poco deteriorando y aunque si china
tiene muchas fortalezas lo cierto es que
la prosperidad explosiva que durante
años ha caracterizado a este país ha
desaparecido así que importa mucho más
el control social político y económico
del partido comunista que el nivel de
prosperidad así que digamos que con el
china está frenando en seco su apertura
incluso se está haciendo otra vez más
totalitaria con todas las consecuencias
que eso tiene pero sea como sea ahora la
pregunta es qué diantres quiso hacer el
gobierno chino para evitar esta crisis
pues amigos amigas probablemente tirar
de las viejas recetas de siempre el
problema es que esta vez pueden no ser
suficientes por un lado para evitar la
crisis el gobierno chino siempre ha
recurrido a los estímulos fiscales y
sobre todo a los estímulos monetarios es
decir a expandir el gasto público y
aumentar mucho muchísimo la concesión de
crédito recordáis que china ha bajado
los tipos de interés pues exactamente
eso también han aprobado grandes líneas
de préstamos para las empresas y están
reduciendo los requisitos para comprar
viviendas en el pasado esto ha
funcionado sin embargo lo hizo a costa
de incrementar mucho la deuda en
circulación y ahora pues ya aparece
demasiado alta como para que estas
políticas puedan tener mucho más
recorrido de hecho durante los últimos
meses la oferta monetaria ha crecido
mucho más rápido que el stop de crédito
y eso eso es lo que explica noticias
cómo están los nuevos pero estamos
bancarios de china caen más de lo
esperado en medio de los nervios
inmobiliarios además bajar tipos cuando
la reserva federal está haciendo
exactamente lo contrario puede aumentar
la salida de capitales del país
[Música]
bien luego por otra parte el presidente
siguiente le ha pedido un esfuerzo a
todos los actores públicos por aumentar
el gasto en infraestructuras y que éstas
puedan convertirse en una especie de
amortiguador económico ante el frenazo
del sector inmobiliario
14 de julio del 2022 china prepara 11
billón de dólares para apoyar el impulso
a las infraestructuras de sí sin embargo
un momento porque no resulta tan
sencillo porque pues porque una de las
principales fuentes de financiación de
los gobiernos locales y regionales es
precisamente la venta de tierras y los
ingresos procedentes del sector
inmobiliario y sabéis que ha ocurrido
pues que las ventas de tierra se han
hundido un 30 por ciento en los últimos
12 meses y esto es lo que explica que
estos gobiernos hayan empezado el 2022
emitiendo deuda a ritmo récord para
financiar todo tipo de infraestructuras
como por ejemplo parques industriales
red de transporte proyecto de agua redes
móviles o centros de datos lo que nos
vuelva a llevar directamente al problema
que veíamos antes y sin fin está
tratando de mantener el crecimiento
económico de china a base de emitir
deuda y construir estructuras que no son
rentables porque la mayoría de ellas no
se necesitan y como no son rentables una
vez que se terminan de construir ya no
aportan crecimiento a la economía pero
la deuda y los intereses se quedan
en resumen puede que china siga teniendo
muchas fortalezas y muchos sectores que
van viento en popa sin embargo su
situación macro se ha ido deteriorando y
mucho durante los últimos años y ahora
el país parece a punto de enfrentarse a
una crisis económica y quizás también
financiera sin que esté nada claro como
demonios espera al gobierno afrontarla
porque tal y como habéis visto pues
puede que está bien las recetas de
siempre no funcione puede significar
esto que la época de gran crecimiento
chino ha llegado a su fin pues ojo
porque cada vez son más los analistas
que apuntan precisamente a esta
posibilidad próximamente en si lo
hubiera sabido en otras muchas más
detalles sobre esta cuestión pero con
todo quizás el mayor problema es que sin
fin quiera compensar el peor rendimiento
económico con un nacionalismo mucho pero
que mucho más agresivo eso es
exactamente lo que hemos visto durante
la última crisis de taiwán y eso eso
sería algo malo para todos pero llegados
hasta aquí turno para ti y crees que
china terminarás sumergiéndose en una
dura crisis económica o por el contrario
crees que logrará sortear todos sus
problemas crees que se puede colapsar el
llamado modelo chino quiera siguen team
para afrontar todos estos problemas como
siempre podéis dejarnos por aquí abajo
los comentarios vuestras opiniones y así
abrir debate y por supuesto si este
vídeos ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis de la like y suscribiros aviso
políticos si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho una vez más gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]